Thank you to Skillshare for supporting this
episode of Journey to the Microcosmos.
And if you’re one of the first thousand
people to click the link in the description
you can get a two-month free trial of Skillshare’s
Premium Membership.
When you go for a walk and feel, perhaps,
the soft “squish” of nature underneath
your feet, you are in fact walking along the
home of plants and fungi and microbes.
The soil itself might just seem like dirt,
common, ubiquitous, mundane.
But dirt is essential.
It is where everything you eat comes from.
It recycles waste.
It cleans water.
It makes your life better in millions of tiny
ways you never notice.
And also...it is mysterious: housing a complex
network of reactions between plants and microbes.
We can’t see it with our eyes, but it’s
like an economy built on chemical signals
and nutrients and competition that take place
in the microcosmos, but that shape the macro
world as well.
Now, microbes require water to thrive, which
can be challenging in soil.
On this channel, we’ve seen many examples
of the protective cysts that many microbes
form when the habitat around them dries out,
like these ciliates that will remain in this
state until the conditions become right for
them to emerge again.
But protective cysts are only a small part
of the story.
Soil is itself a mix of organic material,
minerals, water, and air.
And that fraction of water doesn’t just
sustain the plant life we see above ground,
it provides a home to many, many microorganisms
that remain hidden below.
Soil is also not some mound of dirt that would
be uniform but for the interruption of animals
and plant roots.
That world underneath our feet is made up
of layers and zones.
For example, there’s bulk soil, the area
that is untouched by plant roots.
Bulk soil is home to microbes, but at the
turn of the 20th century, a German scientist
named Lorenz Hiltner noticed that the closer
the soil was to a plant’s root, the higher
bacterial activity he would observe.
And from this work, he defined not just a
new term, but a whole new world: the world
of the rhizosphere.
When Hiltner defined the rhizosphere in 1904,
he described it as the area of the soil that
most immediately surrounded a plant root.
But in time, this definition has been expanded
to describe not just the soil around the roots,
but also the parts of the root that get overtaken
by microbes.
But the rhizosphere isn’t just a location.
It’s a whole set of interactions between
plants and microbes.
And with the complex ecological relationship
that builds, the soil of the rhizosphere can
actually look quite different from bulk soil,
from the types of nutrients to its pH.
But different plants have different needs,
and so the rhizosphere is a dynamic and varied
thing that changes according to the microbial
communities that inhabit it and the complicated
chemical language they share.
In the big picture, roots provide structure
to plants.
But they also play an important role in the
rhizosphere, sending out chemical signals
that attract microbes.
These chemicals can include everything from
free oxygen to water to enzymes to mucilage
to proteins to all sorts of other things.
Collectively, these compounds are known as
the “root exudate.” and they might be
part of a plant’s waste that gets excreted
through the root and into the surroundings.
Or they might be released either actively
or passively from root cells.
Very broadly, the role of root exudate is
to attract microbes.
In some terms, you could consider it an invitation,
but it’s an invitation that comes with a
cost for the plant.
Some of those exudates are nutrients the plant
themselves could use, so why spend them on
an invitation?
What can the microbes bring in exchange?
Well, for one, microbes help plants access
nutrients they might have trouble getting
on their own.
Above ground, plants can access carbon dioxide,
water, oxygen, and light.
And below ground, they get structure and many
of the additional mineral elements they need
to survive.
But some elements, like nitrogen, are pretty
difficult for plants to get.
Nitrogen is essential for life, and it is
also plentiful, but it is so difficult to
convert Nitrogen into the forms life needs
and plants aren’t able to do that.
Instead, they rely on the bacteria of the
rhizosphere to take Nitrogen and convert it
into ammonia and other compounds that they
can actually use.
Some plants, like legumes, even form nodules
on their roots to house those bacteria, creating
an even tighter symbiotic relationship.
Now, whenever you invite someone over, there’s
a little bit of a risk to that, especially
when, you know, sometimes people misunderstand
the nature of the invitation.
Releasing compounds that attract bacteria
is all well and good until the pathogens also
catch wind of what’s going on.
Sometimes these pathogens make it to the plant
and are able to infect it.
But then other times, the non-pathogenic bacteria
can shield the plant, creating protective
biofilms or releasing toxic compounds that
target the pathogens.
Like your good friends that help you kick
that guy out, who I don’t think you even
invited.
But collecting such an active bacterial community
is also a great way to attract predators.
Protozoa and nematodes alike can be found
in the rhizosphere thanks to the buffet of
of bacteria that await them.
And yet this is a risk that plays somewhat
into the plant’s interests as well: as these
predators graze on the bacteria, they excrete
nitrogenous waste that can continue to contribute
to plant growth.
(Or, in some cases, the predator dies, and
they become the source of nutrients.)
The composition of these microbial communities
is shaped by the compounds released by the
plant’s roots.
Scientists are studying the ways these specific
molecules in the root exudate can influence
the presence of specific bacteria and fungi.
As we learn more about the rhizosphere, we
may come to understand not only how these
root exudates influence the ecology of microbes
and plants alike, but how we can better interact
with it when growing our own crops.
These chemical signals and the interactions
they shape form a dialogue between different
parts of the living world.
They speak a language whose basic vocabulary
we may understand, but whose full syntax is
complex and wonderful and mysterious.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
If our pretty images have inspired you to
create some pretty images of your own, and
you’d like some help with that, you can
head on over to Skillshare where there are
classes like “Botanical Illustration Intensive:
Draw Plants Using Science and Style.”
Artist and naturalist, Maggie Heraty will
teach you to create science-based botanical
illustrations of the plants you can find around
you.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that offers membership with meaning.
With so much to explore, real projects to
create, and the support of fellow-creatives,
Skillshare empowers you to accomplish real
growth.
And it makes it easy with short classes that
will fit into your daily routine.
A Premium Membership will give you unlimited
access, so you can join the classes and communities
that are just right for you.
And an annual subscription to Skillshare is
less than $10 a month, and if you’re one
of the first 1,000 people to click the link
in the description, you can get a 2 month
free trial of Skillshare’s Premium Membership.
Journey to the Microcosmos is only possible
because of the support of our patrons.
So, thank you so much to our Patreon community.
These people are the reason this and all of
our other episodes exist.
So, if you liked it, say “Thanks!” to
them.
You can find out more about becoming a patron
at patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam & Germs on Instagram where he is always
posting beautiful and fascinating things.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.